homes these days are equipped with all
sorts of alarms and sensors smoke
detectors beep us awake lights flicker
on when we enter a room and smart
thermostats throttle energy use but
smart houseplants be next indoor
greenery already absorbs the carbon
dioxide we exhale boosts oxygen levels
and brings a calming touch of nature but
some scientists say that houseplants
could do so much more using genetic
engineering they're creating smart
plants that can sense invisible threats
like mold
radon even viral pathogens the method
has already been tested in some crops in
one experiment tobacco plants were
genetically altered to signal when they
encountered bacteria that caused a range
of diseases after exposing the tobacco
to green-light leaves the plants with
bacteria with glow orange which could be
observed with the aid of special goggles
now researchers want to take this
strategy off the farm and into the
household indoors many common species of
mold produce something called volatile
organic compounds chemicals that release
into the air as the molds grow affecting
indoor air quality but bioengineered
house plants could alert homeowners to
such compounds by changing the colors of
their leaves as the plants filter the
surrounding air and heat races would
trigger a reaction causing the leaves to
change color and provide an easy to spot
visual cue this is just the start
researchers believe plants could also be
engineered to detect invisible threats
such as dangerous viruses gases and even
radiation unfortunately while we have a
wealth of information on model plants
like tobacco we still have much to learn
about the basic biology of many plants
in our homes when we finally have enough
data for targeted engineering scientists
say that the homes of the future will
have walls and air vents covered in
smart leaves that can alert homeowners
to a potential drop in air quality in
this lush version of the future you
won't exactly need a green thumb to turn
your ficus into a fungus detector
[Music]